man sieht es erst wenn man ganz genau
hinschaut
es ist unglaublich aber wahr denn dieser
bugatti veyron ist komplett aus lego
gebaut der original sportwagen kostet
rund 2,4 millionen euro
dieses gefährt hingegen besteht aus etwa
einer millionen legosteinen hinter der
aktion steckt das designteam von lego
technic auf der lego webseite wird
berichtet dass die idee dem team
gekommen sei als sie am lego bausatz des
kairo im maßstab eins zu acht arbeiteten
16 personen investierten daraufhin etwa
13.400 arbeitsstunden doch während das
original eine geschwindigkeit von rund
400 km h erreicht muss ich das lego
fahrzeug auf einer teststrecke in
wolfsburg mit etwa 20 km/h zufrieden
geben aber immerhin er fährt